foreign
I don't know what you think you're doing
excuse me hello
got a dead white man in a box
not even a casket doesn't even have a
top on it
in a pine box of old wood what do you
think's gonna get in trouble here
do me a favor try to be optimistic
you don't get here without things
starting a long time ago
[Music]
show Two Soldiers and the nurse found
ourselves in
Amsterdam
we formed the pact and we swore to
protect each other no matter what
we find ourselves in a situation where
we're accused of killing someone which
is not true
Ewan Woodman fled the scene the killer
pointed at us we didn't do anything why
would you possibly think that was us
well there's not too many people that
fit the description of a doctor looking
for his eye on the ground with his black
Attorney Columbia Law School
to find the truth my friend was killed
because of something monstrous that he
had seen
this is all turning out to be a lot
larger than any of us
you're gonna have to take my lead
getting out of this one
I stab a guy I had to hit a lady with a
brick one time what
it's a long story but with Youtube it'll
be a cakewalk
it's a dangerous times you be careful
I'm about to do something that could
cost me my life
[Music]
the cuckoo is in the nest and the cuckoo
is about to be trapped
cuckoo
[Music]
this is one of the finest Innovations
from Zurich it removes all pain
guys like me we have to turn their bows
the morphine and that can lead to
addiction oh that's fast that is
advantage
[Music]
foreign
[Music]